Women’s clothes come in a baffling range
of (often inconsistent) sizes which can make
finding clothes that fit just right an unreasonably
difficult task for many women.
To help combat this, the clothing industry
has a number of tricks up its immaculately
tailored sleeves; in regards to jeans, one
of those tricks is Natasha Wagner’s butt.
Born in 1981, Natasha Wagner took the modelling
world by storm about a decade and a half ago
when it was found that she had the “perfect
butt”.
Since then, she has set the industry standard
for how women’s jeans should fit, working
with big names like Levis, 7 for All Mankind,
Old Navy, Gap, and Paige Denim, among many,
many others.
Now the word “perfect”, especially in
regards to a woman’s posterior is an extremely
subjective thing and different people have
wildly differing ideas of what would make
someone’s backside “perfect”.
But what does it mean for the fashion industry?
A perfect derrière is one that is neither
“too big, too small, too perky or too flat”.
In other words, the perfect caboose is one
that is exceptionally average in every single
way.
Natasha Wagner possesses and painstakingly
maintains such a set of average buns.
Standing at 5 feet 8 inches tall, Wagner is
described as having ideally proportioned hip
to waist measurements, with her 28-inch waist
squarely in the middle of the standard jean
size range.
Wagner was initially unaware of all this until
a friend’s modelling agency took her measurements
out of curiosity in 2001 when they noticed
her petite, but curvy frame.
The agency then passed the measurements on
to a denim company looking for a model of
roughly her build.
That company subsequently hired Wagner to
model a pair of their jeans and found that
they fit her perfectly without any behind
the scenes meddling or camera trickery.
Very quickly, other denim companies began
hiring Wagner to model their jeans and perhaps
more importantly, simply try them on to see
how they fit.
You see, due to her ideal (by fashion industry
standards) measurements, any jeans that fit
her could be reliably expected to fit reasonably
well a range of other women, since, as mentioned,
Wagner’s 28 inch waist falls right in the
middle of the standard jean-size range which
goes from 24 to 32 inches.
Elaborating on this, fashion designer Julien
Jarmoune said that Wagner possesses, “The
perfect marriage of body types…
Because if you fit with someone who is too
curvy (tiny waist, big butt), or with someone
who has a straight body (no hips), you are
limiting yourself to just a certain body type.
A jean that is fit on a straight body will
never look good on someone who has curves.
That’s why Natasha comes into play perfectly.
She has the best of both worlds where she’s
slim and she still has shape.
Additionally, she has great legs that are
the perfect length (she fits our standard
30-inch leg inseam flawlessly) so that our
jeans will work for someone who is short or
tall.”
So by making a design that fits Wagner perfectly,
then scaling the size of the jeans that fit
her up or down, jean makers can essentially
make a single design for a pair of pants that
will be at least in the ballpark of fitting
women of most body types.
As a result, since her initial foray into
the world of modelling, Wagner has been used
as a template of sorts for the fashion industry,
often being called in just to put on a new
pair of jeans to see if they fit.
On top of this, due to her experience in the
industry that has consisted almost exclusively
of trying on jeans, Wagner is today also called
upon as a jean expert, being consulted by
various designers and manufacturers alike
to offer advice on improvements that could
be made to their products.
As Re/Done co-founder Sean Barron said, “She
has a complete understanding of what makes
a jean fit.”
Wagner herself stated,
Once I had learned the jean terminology, I
began to help designers flesh out details
or catch things that may have been overlooked.
They’re busy, they’re working on the current
season plus a year ahead.
I’m just focusing on fit and am able to
point out specifics like if the back rise
is pulling or if there’s bubbling or roping.
A lot of the time you’ll get what’s called
‘slippage’ on a jean, where the denim
pulls and you can kind of see the weft in
the garment.
So I can recommend trying a different type
of construction or a different side seam.
I know how the body should look in the jean,
so I’m able to tell them things like, ‘Kick
out the back rise,’ or ‘Take a measurement
from the top of the rise and add it to the
bottom of the rise to give it a nicer butt
shape and a lift.’
In order to maintain her self-described “median”
figure, Wagner subjects herself to a strict
diet and training regiment that consists of
squats (a drastically underrated exercise
for both men and women), running and time
on an elliptical machine.
In regards to Wagner herself, she feels: “Very
flattered that anyone would say that I have
a perfect butt.”
Adding that when she was first informed of
her measurements that she felt as though she’d
“won the lottery” because they were exactly
the measurements the fashion industry was
looking for in someone to model jeans, allowing
her to enjoy a lucrative, if somewhat unusual
career in one of the most highly competitive
industries on Earth.